hey guys now I never knew just how big
an influence testosterone has over us
men until I really started to look into
it and that's why you guys are seeing me
making more and more videos about
testosterone and if you haven't watched
any of them then you need to know that
low testosterone might give you low
self-esteem lack of energy low sex drive
depression weight gain moodiness thinner
bones low sperm count and even man boobs
hair lots lots of muscle mass and a few
other things but the worst thing about
this is that we get low testosterone
from doing everyday things normal habits
and we don't even know it so that's what
I want to warn you against in this video
let's get to it
[Music]
make mistakes but mistakes make you
strong I just very quick if it's your
first time here on my channel I'm Daniel
and welcome to DLM model lifestyle if
you haven't yet please subscribe and
then also click that notification bell
so you won't miss any of the next videos
now let's start with the first everyday
thing or habit that can give you low
testosterone
the year or more accurately the hops in
the beer lowers testosterone why well
they realized that it contains estrogen
properties in it they started to do a
lot more research on this and now
they're actually starting to use it in
the treatment of women with hot flashes
and then of course guys who drink a lot
well if drinking beer cause them to
sleep a lot less and that takes us to
our next point sleep if you don't get
enough sleep
it will also lower your testosterone
levels I've talked a lot about the
importance of good quality sleep on a
lot of videos and I hope that is
starting to sink in because sleep
doesn't just influence your energy
levels it also influences your central
nervous system your immune system
respiratory system digestive system
cardiovascular system and also your
induction system so it influences your
overall health a bad unhealthy diet look
if you're gonna eat junk food all the
time you will feel like junk food a bad
diet will lower your testosterone levels
it is true what they say you are what
you eat and if you don't know how to
maintain a healthy diet plan or just how
to live a healthy lifestyle then I'll
add some good videos for in the video
description that you can check out
stress my stress is increasing worldwide
and it affects so many things like your
testosterone levels see here's the thing
when you stress your cortisol goes up
we're not happens your testosterone
levels drop so when the one goes up the
other one goes down and vice versa so a
good thing to remember is that 90% of
the things that you stress about will
probably never happen and so the idea
here is to learn how to control your
thoughts to choose one thought over the
other eating and drinking out of BPA
containers vice phenol a is so bad for
your health
and it will lower your testosterone I
don't even understand why they are
allowing it in public use BPA is in
plastics and it is also as xenoestrogen
which is a hormone that imitates
estrogen so instead of using plastic BPA
containers just use metal or glass
containers now just a bonus tip I've
talked about a bad unhealthy diet and
you need to know that obese men have up
to 50 percent less testosterone than
normal men according to studies from the
journal Clinical Endocrinology but apart
from being obese if you don't have a
balanced nutritional plan
it will greatly affect your testosterone
levels meaning if you constantly overeat
or change your diet plan all the time
then it can lower your testosterone
levels so all you got to do is maintain
a healthy nutritional plan of healthy
protein healthy carbs and healthy fat
and then you also need food with zinc
and vitamin D that will boost your
testosterone levels now if you don't
know what your testosterone levels are
then you can test it with let's get
checked I got you guys a 20% discount
from them and I've added it for you in
your video description if you want to
check it out now if you're new here to
my channel you might like one of these
videos and I'll see you there
sorry guys